my first time in the pool i was 49 years
old
my coach was in the water
telling me jump in vivian
he said haven't you been baptized
i said not like this
i was afraid
what is going to happen to me in all
this water
the kids said look at that old lady
trying to learn how to swim
and i said to myself why not now
and i jumped in
i heard
that blind people can't swim
[Music]
oh yes they can
and here you are showing off your first
medal at your first senior olympics oh
you were so proud of that and now you
have accumulated how many
221
and still racking them up here's the l.a
times article doctor's warning made a
champion of her you took that water and
ran with it didn't you
when i was 50
the doctor told me i was gonna die if i
didn't lose the weight
i was
320 pounds i had my teeth wired
to lose weight
that was so dangerous
something
clicked into my head
i realized it's up to me to take control
you're kicking my butt
yeah you are you should see it
wow
i went from a size 24 to a size 12.
i look
delicious
i look good
i'm healthier i have more energy
i started a foundation
that teaches swimming lessons free
i become a city commissioner for people
with disabilities
[Music]
on my 71st day i got up rejoicing
[Music]
my work is not finished
[Music]
you